We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This week the radio audience got a rebroadcast of episode number 10 about Chris Downey, the blind architect, which is often cited as an audience favorite, so you should go
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。了解更多信息请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。本周，广播听众收听了关于盲人建筑师克里斯·道尼的第10集重播，这一集经常被听众评为最爱，所以你们应该去
download it if you haven't heard it already, that's episode number 10, called 99% sound and feel. But for you podgasters, I'm pushing out a special, never before released piece that served as the basis for episode number 3. I'm 99% invisible, but it's never aired and it's full glory until now. Think of it as a. Slightly thesis shifted, double-length director's cut of episode number three. The story is about how a new technology in this case, the smartphone and the RJDJ adaptive music app can not only change your consumption of music but can also change the very nature
下载它（如果你还没听过的话），那是第10集，名为《99%的声音与感觉》。但对于各位播客听众，我推出了一段从未发布过的特别内容，它曾是第3集的基础。我是“99%隐形”，但它直到现在才以全貌播出。你可以把它看作是第3集的一个主题略有调整、双倍长度的导演剪辑版。这个故事讲述了一种新技术——在这个案例中是智能手机和 RJDJ 自适应音乐应用程序——如何不仅能改变你消费音乐的方式，还能改变音乐本身的本质
of music itself. I think it's actually a pretty stunning development in the evolution of music and has even bigger implications than it seems on the surface. So check it out. When I moved out to San Francisco a dozen years ago, I stopped over in LA to visit my friend Max. And as he drove me around the Hollywood Hills, the song Screen Riders Blues by Soulcoffee and came on the car stereo.
音乐本身。我认为这实际上是音乐演变中一个相当惊人的发展，其潜在影响甚至比表面上看起来还要大。所以去看看吧。当我十二年前搬到旧金山时，我在洛杉矶停留，去拜访我的朋友马克斯。当他开车带我穿过好莱坞山时，汽车音响里传来了 Soulcoffee 的歌曲《Screen Riders Blues》。
Exits to freeways twisted like knots on the finger. car stereo. And it seemed to sync up with everything in the world at that moment. When the turn signal was flipped on, it always kept the beat. Headlights whizzed by in concert with the bass loop, and the song would crescendo just as a new amazing vista presented itself through the windshield. It is why they am. And you are listening to lots and joy. If you're of the Walkman generation or the iPod generation or if you take a lot of drugs, you've probably had this happen to you.
高速公路的出口像手指上的结一样扭曲着，车里的音响播放着。在那一刻，它似乎与世界上的万物都同步了。当转向灯亮起时，它总是踩着节拍。前灯呼啸而过，与低音循环相呼应，而就在透过挡风玻璃展现出全新绝美景致时，歌曲推向了高潮。这就是为什么我是...而你正在收听的是 lots and joy。如果你是随身听一代或 iPod 一代，或者你嗑药很多，你大概也经历过这种事。
And Michael Bridenbroker is a big fan of the sort of musical serendipity. That for me was always very magical moments. That's one of the reasons he created RJ DJ. A musical iPhone app that tries to give you that feeling every time you put on your headphones. We're combining the world around you with your listening experience. So, you know, the door closes and something really amazing acoustically could happen. Then I'm always feeling like I'm more in a movie The door closes and something really amazing acoustically could happen.
迈克尔·布里登布罗克是这种音乐奇遇的超级粉丝。对我和我而言，这始终是非常神奇的时刻。这也是他创建 RJDJ 的原因之一。这是一个音乐 iPhone 应用程序，试图在你每次戴上耳机时给你那种感觉。我们将你周围的世界与你的聆听体验结合起来。所以，你知道的，门关上的声音，可能会在声学上发生一些非常奇妙的事情。然后我总是觉得自己更像是在一部电影里。门关上的声音，可能会在声学上发生一些非常奇妙的事情。
Then I'm always feeling like I'm more in a movie, but basically take the movie away and put your life into it, and that's RJDJ. Robert Thomas is one of RJDJ's composers. RJDJ creates what we call reactive music, which is a new format of music, which changes in relation to what you're doing. RJ DJ is comprised of scenes, which are analogous to songs, but there are more like instructions for songs.
然后我总是觉得自己更像是在电影里，但基本上就是把电影拿掉，把你的生活放进去，这就是 RJDJ。罗伯特·托马斯是 RJDJ 的作曲家之一。RJDJ 创造了我们所说的反应式音乐，这是一种全新的音乐格式，它会根据你的行为而改变。RJDJ 由场景组成，这类似于歌曲，但它们更像是歌曲的说明书。
There are bits of music, code for the iPhone's own built-in synthesizer, audio filters, and these are triggered by the user, according to the composer's plan for the scene. I call this quantum composing. You think of all these different possible ways that it could be listened to, and try to come up with lots of different ways that that will create something very interesting to happen in the music. When a sound coming in from your surrounding is very loud,
里面有一些音乐片段、为 iPhone 内置合成器编写的代码、音频过滤器，这些都是根据作曲家对场景的规划由用户触发的。我称之为量子作曲。你想到了所有这些可能被聆听的不同方式，并试图想出许多不同的方法，在音乐中创造出非常有趣的事情。当你周围的声音非常大时，
you could have lots of really fine notes kind of going. Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do- You can have all kinds of path changes in the music based on the analysis of their behavior in their environment. So, sounds like Mike changed the song. But so does the accelerometer in the phone, that's the thing that senses movement. Time spent listening can be a factor, and even GPS data can be incorporated. And all these stimuli work in concert to create an augmented reality. Which is the kind of mind-blowing thing when you're listening to it. The way I see it is it kind of feels like you're seeing some inner beauty and everything. And I think that's where the really great scenes that people have made so far really work.
你可以有很多非常精细的音符在播放，嘟-嘟-嘟-嘟……你可以根据对其环境中行为的分析，在音乐中进行各种路径改变。所以，听起来像是迈克换了歌。但手机里的加速度计也是如此，那是感应运动的东西。聆听时间可以是一个因素，甚至可以纳入 GPS 数据。所有这些刺激共同作用，创造出一种增强现实。当你聆听时，这真是一种令人大开眼界的体验。在我看来，它有点像是让你看到了万物内部的美。我认为这正是人们迄今为止制作的真正伟大的场景发挥作用的地方。
I mean, the most famous one that people get that from is a single eargasm, which is this kind of harmonic overlay over reality. I had my wife May put in the patented white earbuds and check out one of the scenes for the first time. This one's probably the girl. Sorry. Wow. It's what, there's still grudder when It's what I still grudder would hear, I still grudder could hear.
我的意思是，人们从中获得这种体验最著名的场景是单一高潮（single eargasm），这是一种对现实的某种谐波叠加。我让我的妻子梅戴上那副获得专利的白色耳机，第一次体验其中一个场景。这个大概是那个女孩。抱歉。哇。这是什么，当...时仍然有杂音。这是我仍然能听到杂音的，我仍然能听到杂音的。
It's kind of like being in a horror movie, but not quite horrible. You know, it definitely has a horror movie soundtrack. It's got to be like, something that is coming, but we haven't hit the... Oh, but now we have, because there it is. like something that is coming but we haven't hit the thingy thingy you know yet oh but now we have because there it is so most users report that the eargasm scene makes them hear the beauty and all
这有点像是在恐怖电影里，但又不太可怕。你知道，它绝对有一个恐怖电影的配乐。它一定像是有什么东西要来了，但我们还没碰到……哦，但现在我们碰到了，因为就在那里。就像有什么东西要来了，但我们还没碰到那个什么什么东西，你知道的，还没呢，哦，但现在我们碰到了，因为就在那儿。所以大多数用户报告说，那个高潮场景让他们听到了所有事物和环境中的美，而在我妻子听的时候，她说感觉更像是一部恐怖电影，这简而言之就是 RJDJ 的本质，就好像我们以前看的是默片，而现在你突然置身于一部考验配乐的电影中。可能性是无限的。如果有人把《谍影重重》的追车音乐变成一个无休止的反应式音乐场景，我发誓CIA没有任何办法能阻止我。
things and in the environment where my wife is listening she said it felt more like a horror movie and that's kind of RJ DJ in a nutshell it's almost as if we have been in a silent movie before and now you're all of a sudden in a movie that tests a soundtrack. The possibilities are endless. If someone made the born identity chase music into an endless reactive music scene, I swear there is nothing the CIA could do to stop me.
是的，你没听错，帕内塔。但 RJDJ 的创造者并不满足于仅仅改变你对现实的感知。他们实际上希望改变音乐本身。要理解这种对音乐创作的进步所带来的后果，你必须从一个非常长的时间尺度来看待它。在几千年前，音乐大概是在人与人之间传递的东西。当一首歌被听到并被其他人重现时，它一直在不断变化。
Yeah, you heard me, Panetta. But the makers of RJDJ aren't content simply changing your perception of reality. They're really looking to change music itself. To understand the sort of consequences of this advancement to composition of music, you kind of have to look at it over a really wide time scale. And thousands of years ago music was something that I guess passed between people. And as a song was heard and replayed by someone else, it changed constantly.
相对而言，不久前我们发明了记谱法，试图以某种更确定的形式记录下音乐是什么。然后最近我们习惯了这样一种想法：音乐可以被记录并冻结在时间里，变成某种概念上的对象，这个对象可以是一张CD、一张黑胶唱片、一盘磁带或一个 MP3。它们在概念上完全是一回事。而在这一点上，一首歌的单一版本、一首歌的单次表演成了这首歌。那几千年的可变性结束了。
Relatively recently we've invented notation which tries to record what that is, what piece of music is in some kind of more definite form. And then very recently we've got used to the idea that music can be recorded and frozen in time into some form of conceptual object and that object could be a CD, a piece of vinyl, a tape or an MP3. They're all conceptually exactly the same thing. And at this point, a single version of a song, a single performance of a song became the song. And those thousands of years of mutability ended.
但 RJDJ 的技术结束了这一切。现在，录音室实际上就在 iPhone 内部。这基本上就是 RJDJ 的真正所在——一个在 iPhone 内部的录音室。当这种情况发生时，当音乐的交付点实际上就是录音室本身时，就会发生一些非常神奇的事情，因为这意味着那种混音、那种在录音中将音乐在时间中冻结的方式不再真正必要了。这意味着你可以拥有体验一所以，这有点像是你可以探索的音乐世界
But the technology of RJ DJ puts an end to that. Now, the studio is actually inside the iPhone. And that's essentially what RJ DJ is really is a studio inside an iPhone. When that happens, when the delivery point of music is actually a studio itself, something really magical happens because it means that that mix down, that way of freezing music in time in a recording is no longer really necessary. It means that you can have multiple possible ways of experiencing a piece of music. So it's kind of like worlds of music that you can
探索。RJDJ 的承诺是与你周围环境无与伦比的音乐同步。RJDJ 的听众不是戴上耳机去隔绝外部世界，而是接入一个不断变化的、独特的声景，将他们与他们正在做的事情以及他们在世界上的位置联系起来。我幻想着走在旧金山街头，听着朋克和嘻哈的混合音乐，它讲述着我所穿过街区的历史。当我穿过纳皮尔时，GPS 会触发阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的《迷魂记》中的一个声音剪辑。
explore. The promise of RJ DJ is an unparalleled musical synchronicity with your surroundings. Rather than putting on a set of headphones to block out the rest of the world, RJ DJ listeners will plug into a constantly changing, unique soundscape that connects them to what they're doing and where they are in the world. I imagine walking around San Francisco, listening to a mashed up composition of punk and hip hop that gives me a history of the neighborhood I'm traveling through. And the GPS will trigger a sound clip from Alphechcock's Vertigo when I pass through NAPIL.
当我为了躲避一个讨厌的自行车信使而仓皇逃窜，却差点撞上一辆毫不起眼的迎面开来的缆车时，节奏会加快。我躺在人行道上突然一动不动，会从 iPhone 耳机中引出一个令人愉悦的谐波持续音，它将与走近的医护人员的警笛声完美地融合在一起。站住！或者你可以选择你自己的冒险。好吧，这就是本周的节目。
And the tempo will speed up as I scurry out of the way of an obnoxious bike messenger into the path of an unnoticed, oncoming cable car. My sudden lack of all movement as I lie on the pavement will elicit a pleasing harmonic drone from the iPhone earbuds which will mix beautifully with the sirens from the paramedics as they approach. Stop! Or you can choose your own adventure. Well that's the show for this week.
希望你们喜欢。在接下来的几周里请继续收听，因为我有很多自己的故事，还有一些世界上最好的广播制作人的故事，他们碰巧是我的朋友，他们为“99%隐形”制作节目真是太棒了。我为此感到非常高兴。所以请继续关注。并宣传出去。你们一直都太棒了。
I hope you enjoyed it. Stay tuned in the coming weeks because I have lots of stories from me as well as stories from some of the best radio producers in the world who happen to be friends of mine, which is rockin' that they're doing pieces for 99% of visible. I'm so happy about that. So stay tuned for that. And spread the word. You guys have been so great.
所以请转发推特、写博客、发脸书（Facebook），在脸书上加入并点赞。我真的非常感激。我还在为今年下半年的资金努力。所以你能做的任何宣传都会对我们有所帮助。好的，非常感谢。保重。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。快来参与吧。再见。
So Twitter and blog and Facebook and join up on Facebook and like it on Facebook. I would really appreciate it. I'm still trying to get funding for the back half of the year. So everything you can do to spread the word helps us out. All right, thanks so much. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以去发推特、写博客、用Facebook，在Facebook上关注并点赞吧。我真的非常感激。我还在为今年下半年的资金来源四处奔走。所以你能做的任何宣传对我们都有帮助。好的，非常感谢。保重。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。